it's that time again to talk to you
about the latest games in new releases
and this week you say goodbye to your
family and the Sun because you will
never leave your house again with a week
so jam-packed of amazing releases why
not start it off with a game more
addictive than red lyrium dragon age
inquisition our own kevin van word
reviewed the game with a glowing 9 at a
10 praising the game's tremendous cast
of interesting and relatable characters
a massive and diverse environment and
deep choices that lead to adventure
triumph and heartbreak and Dragons start
closing riffs November eighteenth oh but
we're just getting started because this
week you put on your hunting boots your
hunting cap and you're hunting rocket
launcher it's time to traverse the
Himalayas and kill you some elephants
I'm sorry majestic beasts but you'll
need to practice for when those honey
badgers start attacking you they take no
[ __ ] from no man start skinning November
eighteenth onward we go to good looking
high-definition GTA 5 because it's
releasing on ps4 and xbox one this week
both versions will run at 1080p and 30
frames per second and both will
introduce an exclusive new first-person
mode ensuring you really get a true
feeling of what it's like to live life
through the eyes of Trevor that's not
worth a full-price game see you online
October 18 but we're still not done yet
because sackboy is back with a bunch of
helpful buddies like toggle odd sock and
sweep they work together to go on large
adventures and collect stickers but
don't forget that you can have user made
levels now ensuring there's no limit to
the creativity and fun with in this game
little big planet debuts on the 18th
but what's this now a surprise it's
never alone a puzzle game Reese wat
between a little girl named nuna and her
arctic fox complete puzzles based on
Alaskan indigenous stories including
that of Blizzard man the little people
manslayer the rolling heads and sky
people it looks cute as hell but with
complex puzzles it's certainly something
to get excited about the cute overload
begins on the 18th now you sit back down
because we're not done yet Pokemon Omega
Ruby and Pokemon alpha sapphire come to
your 3ds this week discover the secrets
behind mega evolution said to be the
greatest mystery of the Pokemon world
check out the Pokemon lab in littleroot
town before starting your journey to the
Pokemon gyms where you'll take on the
leaders for your fancy badges this game
will also keep the feature from pokemon
X&Y where you get to pet play and feed
your Pokemon to make them love and bond
with you it's so cute but happier
Pokemon avoid more attacks and land more
critical hits making them vicious
killing machines and are so cute start
your army November 21st all just one
more Super Smash Bros jumps from the 3ds
to Wii U this week the wii u version
features high-definition graphics and a
special mode that allows up to 8 players
simultaneously which will obviously
result in absolute pandemonium the wii u
version also features 3 exclusive new
game modes smashed or special orders and
event mode so collect and play all 49
playable fighters except the Wii Fit
ones which are stupid and start playing
now or when it comes out on the 21st for
further details visit gamespot com
release dates are based on retailer
listings and are subject to change see
you next week